[Musique]
l' enquête se poursuit après la mort
d'une directrice de la photographie tué
accidentellement sur le tournage d'un
western au nouveau mexique par alec
baldwin nous avons deux personnes qui
ont été blessés accidentellement par un
pistolet nous avons besoin d'être
immédiatement est-ce qu'ils sont
conscients
oui sont conscients
c'est vous madame manière fort que moi
oui mes collègues
l'armure hier qui était en charge sur le
tournage la voici anna reid 24 ans
c'était seulement son deuxième film et
coûtent les bien ce qu elle confié à une
radio locale il ya peu je viens de finir
mon premier job en tant qu'art mur hier
j'étais super nerveuse j'ai même failli
refuser le poste parce que je ne me
sentais pas capable femme qui portera
aux fans de notre pays une attention
nouvelle pour celles vers tête et
souffre
de violence et de vie
nous sommes tous derrière toi tous
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas d'union de la gauche
possible lorsque vous voyez jean luc
mélenchon et anne hidalgo qui continuent
à se battre avec françois hollande au
dessus à régler des comptes sur le
quinquennat à l'antépénultième deux
quinquennats je suis là je me bats pour
ça je me battrai et je me battrai pour
vous jusqu'à la victoire c'est facile de
distribuer son héros surtout avec de
l'argent qui sera pris soin par les
impôts soit par la dette monsieur macron
mais un clientélisme à l'échelle
absolument gigantesque on a rarement vu
une politique clientéliste aussi massive
moi je vais demander l'interdiction de
cette mesure de façon préventive car il
s'agit de l'utilisation de l'argent de
l'état défunt de campagne électorale ce
qui est réprimée par la loi par des
peines d'infractions pénales et laboeuf
ans pour une partie des dalton habitué
des rodéos sauvages en plein centre
ville de lyon ces individus vêtus de
jaune et noir ont été surpris hier par
an dispositif de police trois d'entre
eux ont été interpellés et placés en
garde à vue on passe son temps à
emmerder les français moi je pense qu'il
faudrait arrêter cela par exemple c'est
à dire un exemple bah oui par exemple
supprimé le permis à points le pam est à
point aujourd'hui a entraîné une conque
une circonstance qui est dramatique
c'est que des millions de français sont
privés de leur permis de conduire et ils
sont privés pour quoi ils sont privés
parce que bien souvent ils ont fait des
péchés véniels monsieur zemmour c'est
qui c'est un homme pétri d'aigreur et
d'orgueil qui se rêve empreintes et qui
tous les jours
wen vous donnait même pas la peine une
fois la place vous avez tout est trop
vite je voulais reprocher une époque
c'est non non pas du tout c'est
extraordinairement réfléchi et c'est un
tweet sur le fond et quand on dit il ya
un commentaire que c'est pas un
commentaire on a là une personne qui en
fait illustre une position politique
donc j'ai dit comment on va pouvoir
inventer une nouvelle créature qui va
pouvoir encore faire plus peur et jeté
dans les bras
du renouvellement du quinquennat de
macron qui a inventé eric zemmour en
tout cas ils le laissent prospérer
l'encouragent c'est comme ça plante
qu'il arrose tous les matins marine le
pen a enfermé ses électeurs qui sont
pour la plupart des électeurs des
classes populaires ouvriers chômeurs
employés dans un ghetto politique parce
qu'elle n'en sort pas et parce qu'elle
ne les sort pas de ce ghetto c'est à
dire que le vote pour marine le pen ne
sert à rien puisqu'elle ne peut pas
gagner la présidentielle ça ne sert à
rien mais voyez on est encore nommé
nacre en ont mais les attaques contre
moi comme toutes les autres d'ailleurs
elles sont gratuites
la plupart sont d'ailleurs des vieilles
attaque recycler des délais requis m'ont
attaqué sur ce sujet pendant des années
des années